this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia.edu good afternoon to everyone
I'm a little bit vertically challenged
so you may just see a talking head for a
while it doesn't help that the lights
are shining directly on so I can't
really see the screen very well so bear
with me I just wanted to just go back a
little bit and speak a little bit about
what professor Wallace doctor also said
this morning about the importance of
really keeping that a equals B dynamic
it is so important to make sure that we
are talking to each other that we
engaging in dialogue that we are really
addressing all of the issues on an equal
basis that we are not looking at the
hierarchy and as I decided to create a
copper coil focus on familiar I'll
charge you to really think about what
that actually means focus on failure we
could look at it in two different ways
we could say we're focusing on the areas
that don't work just for the sake of it
giving us all the opportunities to make
excuses for what we are unable to do
because of lack of funding because of
lack of staff to available to do what
they need to do because of many
different reasons however I really
challenge you to look at the second
component of that because when we're
focusing on failure it's really looking
at the different opportunities that we
may have to find oil
areas where we have weaknesses I really
take those weaknesses and create some
strings from that we're going to look at
the areas that haven't worked and then
change those so that we could learn from
them gain experience from them and
collaborate with other groups in order
to make the real models of success if we
start looking at what those models of
success are looking at two kinds of
failures and we know that they're those
who think and never do theoretical
constructs are really important we need
to know what's behind it we need to be
able to plan things appropriately
however if we remain forever in the
planning stage and we are afraid to take
the next step to implement those things
that we're actually planning then it's
really a moot point what are we actually
accomplishing we're really not able to
learn because as we know from all of the
different discussions that have taken
place many things that happened that
were able to put together theoretically
are really not able to be we're not able
to fix them we're not able to evolve
with them we're not able to change them
without the opportunity to really
practice what we are talking about to
really focus on some of those different
areas and using all of those things
those failures those things that have
not worked well to really move forward
and propel us in another area and then
again those who did and never thought we
are talking about health disparities
we're talking about all of the different
the cultural issues the many things that
are closed barriers for people to
receive the services that they need
however when we do things without
thinking it is the formula for failure
and we want to make sure that not only
do we take the time to think about it
and organize things that need to be
organized but then we also take the time
to take those things and put them to
practice so that we make the work so it
really becomes the balance of the two
and as remember that
there are two benefits to the failure
first that it gives us the opportunity
for to find out what does it work we try
this we try to win a certain population
maybe was a great formula when working
with children when working with one
special population when working with the
highest population but when we tried
that same formula that same plan and we
work with a homeless population where an
adult population we find that it may not
work so well so it is really again
taking the idea and telling the program
to the population that we're working
with and secondly it gives us the
opportunity to try a new approach if it
didn't get work this way let's try it a
different way let's modify it just that
little bit to make sure that we're
actually achieving the outcomes that are
not necessarily the outcomes that we
want as far as the deliverables for a
grant or the deliverables for speaking
to your supervisor but that it actually
provides the support and the services
that are necessary for those families
that need is so very much and as we're
defining failure as a measure of success
the only way to determine how to do
things the right way is to look at what
things did not work so again it said a
repetition of those concepts what are
those things that didn't work one of
those areas that we really need to focus
on a little bit more we achieve success
to know to gain programs about knowledge
in miniature reevaluate we modify
strategies as we go along the more we
engage in contact with our community of
interest the more we we work on all of
those different areas that won't think
really need to be addressed and the more
we really focus on the need for that
population the more we're really going
to understand how to monitor it how to
evaluate it and how to evolve with that
process so as you see when we're looking
at which side of the road we want to be
on how we're going
we're going south and we're going on the
path to success or are we staying in
failure because we are either unwilling
to change or afraid to take that next
step to move forward and as we shift
into success it's really focusing on
what do we do as a group we're
discussing health disparities we're
talking about the importance of working
with people that have different thoughts
different ideas different needs but when
we're working with organizations do we
actually turn around and look at
ourselves as staff members what do we
need to do within the organization to
make sure that those programs are not a
failure when they hit the ground what do
we do as an organization to make sure
that we work cohesively towards the same
agenda and that is to really maintain
the one vision and one approach how do
we get to that by taking everyone around
the table everyone that's part of that
organization and really trying to elicit
an idea from them our third from them so
that it becomes a very collaborative
process we need strong leadership if
it's strong from the top down if it's
drawing from the bottom up those are two
different ways we are only as strong as
for all of our members and if we have a
weak link anywhere it is probably
through that weakness that we're going
to all dissolve and not be able to do
what we need to do properly we need to
have standard protocols and procedures
discretionary spending what do we do
with the money that is afforded to us do
we make sure that it's a very showy
program and we spend the majority of our
money on a media campaign and becoming
well-known or do we take some of that
funding and make sure that it becomes
available to those populations that need
depending on what our program is really
seeking to do and that equation is going
to shift employee development how many
of us have been working in organizations
where all you hear is what's going wrong
over here is oh you
do this or you didn't do that so how
about taking the opportunity to also
acknowledge the people in there doing
things correctly that we need to develop
them and make sure that every
opportunity for training for growth for
working with other people for networking
something that's really advocated for as
part of this conference let's make sure
that all of us again are working
together so that the position that you
start with is not the position that you
end with that there's always an
opportunity for growth and moving
forward and there we form partnerships
and collaborations as we look around us
and we look at the communities that we
work with we realize that many of us may
be working on the same products we're
working to achieve the same goal so how
do we find out about all of those things
that are available within the community
so that we don't duplicate the services
but at the same time we're taking the
strengths of every portion of the the
community every group that's working
together to make sure that we have one
very very strong community working
together to the same one vision one
approach can sometimes its many
approaches that will lead us to that one
vision again at the monitoring and
evaluation also a very important
component of everything we need to make
sure that we keep tabs of everything
that's going on there we evaluate the
programs again with the idea that we
want to make sure that we change things
as they go along but we are flexible
enough to understand where we're doing
things correctly but also humble enough
to understand them we're not doing it
correctly and it needs to be modified
leadership I wanted to break everything
down into two different pieces because
these components become the real essence
of what makes some of the programs work
I had the opportunity to work everywhere
from our organization or substance abuse
to working with our youth groups to
working both in New York in Manhattan
and in the Bronx
on issues around asthma and it becomes
really important but leadership really
I'm sets the tone for what is going to
be accomplished and what we will not be
able to accomplish so as we're declaring
that vision in the approach are we
setting the guidelines are we measuring
ourselves by those guidelines and making
sure that we are accomplishing the
things that we want to accomplish are we
engaging in continuous discussions and
are we engaging in in those discussions
productively at one of our meetings how
many of you again and it's a rhetorical
question but how many of you have gone
to meetings where the only thing that
you hear is statistics this is what we
did these are the numbers that we had
this is all that's been done but when
are we going to engage in a really
working meeting to say these are the
reasons why we did not achieve this goal
this is where we're going as a result of
this number these are the different
areas where we think collaboratively we
will be able to refocus and regain
energy by working together as a team you
may have the knowledge and understanding
of the scope of work for each employee
do we have the ability to report on
programs and employee progress are
related by example so I'm the best I
tell you what to do however I'm on the
phone all the time I don't really
understand the vision I don't really go
out to talk to the population that I'm
supposed to be servicing it's really
easy to sit behind the desk it's really
easy to spend little amounts of time
really engaging the public that you're
supposed to be working with how many
times have you actually got out there
and had conversations with those people
that were supposed to be helping do you
know the faces of those people impacted
by asthma diabetes cancer all of the
different areas that we were focusing on
today and throughout this conference and
beyond do we have a good knowledge
menteur strengths and weaknesses
weakness
is not being able to admit what you
don't know if you go out there and you
say I know everything that is the first
failure because all of us have the
opportunity for additional knowledge the
opportunity to really grow and engage in
different conversations that will lead
us on the path to something bigger and
better than probably any of us could
have imagined as we must maintain and
partiality for again going back to that
speculation of the vision and approach
we know as a collective what it is that
we're trying to do here it is that we're
trying to target so rather than doing
what a lot of times people do to make
nature end up doing and that is to
engage our egos rather than engage our
thoughts is it so important to really
see whose name we will force the
hostname google blast on a publication
or is it more important to discuss how
we're going to achieve this goal so that
every single member on that team is just
as strong as the next one we have a lot
of strong people working with us we have
a strong leadership that is the mark of
successful programs and having good
judgment again if something does it work
I really stay with it are we going to
give it a chance however we give it that
chance and when do we
abandon it sometimes abandoning a
purchase absolutely what you need to do
but making sure that you have good
judgment in doing so when we establish
program structure some of the things
that we really have to focus on include
population or groups of interest who are
we targeting what services will be
rendered again what is the mission and
vision for the program are there similar
programs why are we going to duplicate
services that already exist why are we
going to compete for clients in a very
small community area if we could work
with that community where we can work
with that organization and make sure
that we only enhance the services that
are available so that we take our
strengths and their strengths and we put
them together and we could possibly make
a bigger difference with the communities
that we're working with what resources
are available our resource is only
available if we know that it's there we
could have the best restaurant across
the street and yet you could be starving
what does that mean if you don't know
that that restaurant is across the
street we're not going to know that
units across that Street in order to
access it the same thing with health
care if we don't know about the services
that are available it will take the time
to really look a little bit beyond our
doors you will never determine what
resources are truly available and what
existing partnerships we can engage in
as we set the agenda how we determined
the bulk of time that we need to spend
on doing a lot of things what have we
done what are we unable to do I'll be
stagnated because our funding because of
staffing because of all the difficulties
or we stagnated because our minds don't
let us move beyond the ego they don't
let us move beyond the things that need
to be accomplished they let us move
beyond some of the difficulties and as
dr. Wallace discussed this morning as
dr. Betancourt spoke about as well
communication is absolutely
II if we don't feel empowered by
ourselves what can we do as a team to
gain strength from each other what can
we do to move that vision forward and
set the agenda deprive the proper way as
we're improving communication you make
sure that it within an organization we
have email all of us so we're in the era
of technology so how difficult is it to
add one more name two more names to that
email to make sure that everyone that
needs to know is absolutely absolutely
familiar with the materials that they
need to be familiar with how about
engaging in conversations we have fallen
to the era of technology and I'd say
it's a wonderful thing yet yet is a
terrible thing because now we don't know
how it how to engage others in person
why is it so difficult to pick up the
phone or to walk to someone's office and
say you know we have something in common
there's an interest something we need to
maintain what do we do to move forward
that extra step so take us to that
formula to success where we share
results there has to be transparency and
management we've heard so much through
the presidency how important it is to
have transparency how many people that
again I close all of these questions
there are so many people that were never
interested in politics before people who
never listened to a news conference
before what was that maybe because that
the terminology that was used was above
their heads terminology really means
meant to confuse rather than to
enlighten terminology that was used
because we want to make sure that a
certain small group of people get our
point but those others that could also
benefit and dilute those affluent or
those that are in the greater categories
what are we doing are we really reaching
out to everyone it's the same thing
we're thinking globally as far as the
United States as far as the world is
concerned they were also thinking on
organization level we're thinking on
that individual level what are some of
the areas that we need to focus on to
make sure that that transparency and
management is something that propels us
it makes us move forward in a proper way
the more we know about what is expected
of us the better it is for us to be able
to develop a plan to actually accomplish
those goals we're sharing resources I
could hide a piece of paper that has the
name of an author that's wonderful so I
gained over knowledge all by myself but
then when I need assistance when I need
that team to work together when I need
to promote a certain program how many
people do you think would actually know
the information that would believe
because I've worded the information to
myself so I really gaining or am I
really losing informing or pending
changes or challenges we spend an entire
week and especially during these
economic times it's monday through
friday you have work that is for 35 on a
friday afternoon it would be nice to get
a pink slip on a wednesday so that at
least they'll tell you all you have to
be under the week to work but how do you
feel like a slap in the face right when
it's 445 and they still pack up your
bags because a five o'clock you no
longer work here when we are losing
funding when the staff will that be will
lose a position in a staff member will
not be replaced when we no longer have
access to some of the resources or a
book that was so essential to us for us
to read is no longer going to be
available if we know about it in a best
we were able to accommodate we're able
to cope with those changes if we don't
know about it in advance we get taken by
surprise and that surprise generally
does not lead to good things as we have
changes in protocols and procedures how
could I comply with what needs to be
done if there was a change in the
protocol put someone forgot to tell me
about it
so now i am following the old protocol
and anjali it all wrong most folk is it
is it mine or is it the person who
neglected to tell me and truthful
reporting and we are I would say
prisoners to deliverables we all have to
have successes we have to show that the
money what's being placed in our hands
is being used to the best and the
maximum that it can be used for however
when Jerry go beyond the line just
report vaguely we can do that then we
show advocate data he absolutely can do
that but are we always making sure that
the reports that we provide are truthful
reports are there an accurate
representation if I go out and I see a
child who is poor and hungry and I feed
that child am i able to say the children
are not hungry am i able to generalize
my results if I'm not really focusing on
the area that needs to be involved if I
say that the levels of disease the
prevalence of disease has decreased have
I really looked at all of the population
have I taken a representative sample of
that population and often we find
ourselves stretching the truth a little
bit too much to the point that it
doesn't serve our needs and it most
definitely does not serve the needs of
the population that needs it the most
demanding accountability accurate
reporting as I just mentioned incentives
in words for the performance how good
does it feel when you've done a good job
the entire year and your performance
evaluation not only reflects the work
that you've done and the effort that you
have given but gives you a
an incentive that's money sometimes
that's possible sometimes that's not how
about something as simple as a post-it
note on someone's desk saying good job
you're so valuable to us that is in your
word that is sometimes a more powerful
reward than the money because the money
goes away but the good feeling that you
get as a result of that good job there's
something that could last a lot longer
consequences for perfect performance and
again we have gotten very complacent so
we're not telling people they do a good
job that on the other hand when they're
doing a bad job it's never pleasant to
go to someone and say you're fired or to
go to someone and say you're really not
accomplishing what you need to
accomplish but sometimes it is
absolutely what needs to be done so that
we're making sure that we are staying
with that agenda and I just lost my head
here so if I can get some help that
would be great
I just do it five again I don't that's
what's it
perfect also reducing internal
competition competition is a healthy
thing but only when it doesn't lead us
in circles we offer again ego need for
success for individual a pat on the back
so I'm going to tell us that we are the
best the biggest the strongest that's
wonderful but when that competition
turns into a catfight that nothing can
be accomplished that nothing can move
forward and that's destructive then you
have multiple programs and components
requiring similar outcomes again let's
work together to make sure that we're
all able to accomplish what we need to
accomplish let's look at personal
qualities mothers of a certain sort of
misc levels of focus let's push for
recognition and upward mobility I can
have a staff member working for me who
could very well be more knowledgeable
about a certain area am I going to
squash that or am I going to say you
know whether you have such a strength
let's work together because your
strength may be my weakness but maybe I
have a strength that's your weakness and
you bring me up and I bring you up and
we'll go up together it depends a
competition that is not productive where
you are saying I need to be first I need
to be recognized I'm going to forget to
tell someone about it to give me that
unfair advantage where does that take a
submitter does not take us far but yet
we engage in that every single day and
it may be something that's not in our
nature we're not doing it because we're
malicious some of this movie but it's
really taking all those different
aspects of our personalities may not
taking a collective consciousness
consciousness learning
but more thinking a little bit more
being a little bit more introspective to
understand what we're doing correctly
and what we're doing wrong so that when
we have multiple same level managers
we're all able to say we're going to
work together so that everyone that
works with us is able to see that we are
united and as managers we will set the
example we will lead by that example so
that our workers are able to do what
they need to do denial I didn't do it it
wasn't me was it you it was that guy it
was that girl if we are blind to our
weaknesses and deficiencies we cannot
move further it we need to show positive
results that's absolutely true but we
also need to be confident in the results
that we are portrayed we need to make
sure that those are sustainable results
that those positive results are actually
going to be good for the overall need
for the over a long term goal because we
can have many successes on a short-term
basis but if those things don't lead to
sustainable products if they'll lead to
sustainable services going forward then
again the moment will step away from
that what have we accomplished we're
unwilling to identify poorly performing
staff we have fear of the notion or
Larson status so I think that this is
absolutely well I think that it's going
to be detrimental to the overall focus
of what we're trying to do yet I'm not
going to stand up and say that I
disagree why am I going to shower shyla
debt a spotlight on myself if I don't
need to and there's weapon that
complacency that unwillingness to say
this doesn't work that again could lead
to the failure of a program and we want
to make sure that that does not happen
we have to take into account cultural
diversity among the staff all of these
things that we're focusing on again as
we talk about the populations that we
need to serve part of those members of
the population are the staff members
that work with us there is a difference
in work ethic in someone's understanding
of how to speak up to a supervisor of
someone's ability to do things
independently of someone's ability to
really engage others in conversation and
take a leading position that really
depends on many many factors and we have
to take all of those factors into
consideration when we are working
amongst ourselves and how do we find out
through communication what works for you
what does it work for you is there
something that makes you uncomfortable
and sometimes those are the very
conversations that many of us are
unwilling or unable or just very afraid
to take what do we do so that we can
move forward I will ascertain where are
we passive then we have the power to
speak up then we have something to say
we have two different aspects we have
those that talk a lot and really know
very little and we have those that know
a lot and work very little so where is
the balance and that becomes an
important issue because we need to
empower those that have the knowledge
and don't speak a lot we have to make
them feel comfortable within the setting
so that they are able to speak their
mind so tell you what they believe in to
tell you the some other ideas that
really will make the difference for
whatever you're trying to accomplish
body language I can tell you something
with a smile on my face but be very
really mean I could stay really quiet
yet my face tells you something
different what are the messages that
we're giving to each other amongst our
staff what do we do
to make sure that we are not only
engaging things that are positive but
also dispelling things that are negative
he said she said oh no one told me it's
about again accountability we are
accountable for finding the truth so if
someone does not give you information
and you know that that information is
really important for you to know it is
also your responsibility to go seek that
information because you cannot blame the
next person for not telling you and say
one says they didn't tell me I now do
not have any responsibility you're still
have a responsibility within your
organization and have the responsibility
to yourself to make sure that you are
doing the best that you can and again
that changes with the culture that
changes with beliefs that changes with
sometimes the time that you went to
school and what you were taught and what
your values are what you were taught at
home so it's taking all of those things
into account and making sure that they
work as best as they can you're always
going to find challenges there's no such
thing as an ideal xyn Aereo however how
can we maximize the benefits and reduce
those challenges and we are probably in
one of the worst economic times in a
very very long time we're going to
experience the changes in funding there
are grants that will not be removed
there are programs that will not be
supported programs that we feel are
really important programs and crucial to
the populations and which ones do you
think those will be the massive
populations as dr. sacks on spoke about
we absolutely need to be able to feed
children to provide services to the
sub-saharan African area yet you choose
to for whatever reason we are not
providing those services why so we have
to look at those things what can we do
with the funding that we have with the
resources
that we have that really work to
maximize the benefit even in the face of
the changes in funding when we have
mandatory changes to personnel lines
will realize that maybe we will not be
able to impact as many people as we
thought but is it more efficient to
impact 50 people in a mediocre very a
maybe 25 in an excellent way what are
you choose to give up in order to
accomplish our goals let me talk about
mandatory changes to OTPs OTPs is other
than personnel services and for those of
you that have anything to do with
budgets you realize that there's a lot
of spending that goes on everything from
incentives to program a management that
does not have to deal with the actual
salary of an individual and sometimes we
may not lose people that we lose our
ability to have programs because we
don't have that other than personal
funding and that core so becomes an
issue but again it's about rising above
the challenges and doing the best that
we can with as little as possible
because sometimes that is where we can
do acknowledging the maybe it will not
be within the next hour or it will not
be something that we can do within the
next day or the next year or even the
next decade but eventually if we have
the patience and we have the vision it
is something that collectively we
probably will be able to achieve and as
we're stepping third we're identifying
the programs the patterns that exists
then we're focusing on solutions for
each of them we're naming staff who can
be responsible for addressing these
issues it doesn't necessarily have to be
a director it could be a staff member
who absolutely has the right ingredient
to follow something through how can you
identify the strengths within that
person so that they can
on the path to success when we reconvene
in regularly to see what progress we
have made again I will really engaging
in the discussion about what we fail to
do what are some of the areas that we
need to really exert more energy on
there are we really just reporting that
everyone wants to hear by modifying the
structure how flexible are we so we
could achieve that success are
identifying and implementing measures
for sustainability if we go to a
population one of the wrong things that
I have engaged in the past is really
engaging families and focus groups
working with them providing support for
them because if I teach someone how to
do something and I know that they have
learned what they need to do and they
are empowered to complete the task I
could step away from that with the
feeling that they will be able to
consider that process even I'm not there
because there are changes in funding
you're going to find us some of the
programs are only going to be able to
follow families or or people for a short
period of time and then we need to step
away when you step away what have you
put in place to make sure that it can
continue to grow but the resource even
though you are not there will still
become available to those individuals
and in fairness to all we say the
programs with poor management structure
are usually the first to fail and as we
really think about the issues
surrounding health disparities we
realize that all too often the program
is that for our first are usually those
for disadvantaged populations moving to
additional increases in health
disparities and we need to be able to
provide equity and health we need to be
able to address those issues and very
honestly to talk about those issues so
that we are addressing them as they need
to be addressed good management and
structure together with the necessary
financial resources are really crucial
it is to focus on failure that
is a true model of success but it was
not focusing on merit and failure and
conjuring on that failure it is focusing
on the areas that don't work focusing on
those failures that will make us
stronger because we have actually
learned our lesson and the simple truth
so many of us say afford because it's
someone else's fault because I didn't
have because I couldn't do because of
many many different reasons but the
simple truth is that sometimes food is
bit comes after just one word and that
is procrastination and why do I say that
the more you talk about it the more we
can say that we're doing something but
if it's year after year and I'm still
talking about it and I have not taken
one step further to make sure that I go
from point A to point B what have I
actually accomplished have I really
grown have a little made that program
successful the answer is no we have the
money is sitting in the pack all of us
have padded each other on the back as
much as we can or do they feel good
those people are still hungry the people
still don't have the vaccination in the
medications that they need this people
are still gasping for air because they
don't have the knowledge to be able to
know but they have to take medications
for asthma all of the time even when
they don't have symptoms all of those
things really have to be addressed
because our procrastination is really
what makes it so that those people that
suffer from the biggest areas of health
disparities are those people that
actually suffer the most and have the
most to lose so it is saying but
planning is really important and they
realize that a plan without action is
just as much a failure as having no plan
at all so if we're saying there if the
money in the pot and
had challenged to move forward I will
actually do anything however if we were
to take the trust or theoretical model
will say what's the Jovian we can
concentrate all we want I know I smoke
it's bad for me I'm not going to smoke
tomorrow and then tomorrow as I wake up
I light up that singer once again and
say you know what this is tell why can
not do this anymore tomorrow is another
day and in fact it is there's always an
opportunity to do something another day
however there's no best better thing
than what you can do today start moving
today start going on the point of
contemplation and move forward to
preparation and skip that step plunge
into action because we will realize that
what you feel is something that you're
doing all by yourself you look around
you and people will follow if you can
show them that it's not just words and
there are actions behind what you're
saying you do not have to have your name
first on a publication you do not have
to say look at many many people you'll
notice a you know that
notice because it's not about you people
will notice you on the way to achieving
the goal that needs to be achieved and
if there's one less child that's hungry
in the street if there's one less person
who suffers from domestic violence if we
have address all the issues that need to
be addressed people will notice you so
in putting my name out there especially
for doctoral students especially for
those that are beginning their careers
we understand what the employers really
is drag the girl do what your picture on
the front cover or do you really want to
know that at the end of the day you have
a little change something that has
beneficial to others something that will
work even when you're not there so that
even though your name James from those
lights that benefit will continue to
move forward and having to do that it's
really taking all of those things that
you have learned a little bit early all
of those mistakes that you have made
that you have acknowledged and have more
favorable ond and said these are the
things that I have learned it on below
that have led me on my path to success
thank you very much
any questions comments
yeah thank you
but definitely what I like to do by that
is to start the discussion to give
people things to think about because
sometimes what is staring us in the face
is where we fail to see the obvious is
usually what gets ignored the majority
of the time and we pay attention to
those small details and we focus on
those areas that really need just that
little bit more of attention maybe a
couple of minutes a day that weakens our
vote to that particular issue that will
make all the difference in the world and
let's face it sometimes our programs do
fail that is not to say that by
following a simple step 1 through 10
you're able to engage a successful
products part of the time but sometimes
even with failure very success because
for everything that you are not able to
accomplish with one program just leads
the way it's a recommendation for what
not to do when your funding new programs
really come together it may not be you
again it may not be the one receiving
the glory but it will collectively be a
program that let the way was to stepping
stones for something that's bigger and
better and that's really what I'm trying
to accomplish by this so by when you're
talking about that focus on failure and
saying we need to think about those
words what do they actually mean are we
going to use it to our detriment what
we're going to use it for our benefit
and as to hope that all of us as Public
Health people are health educators as
individuals and family members that we
engage our families our populations of
interest our co-workers in positive ways
so we're able to achieve what we need to
achieve
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu